JAMES WEXLER: I'm James, an
engineer on the What-If Tool.
SARA ROBINSON: I'm Sara, a
developer advocate on Cloud AI
Platform.
JAMES WEXLER: We're
going to give you
an introduction into how you can
use the What-If Tool to better
understand your machine
learning models.
SARA ROBINSON:
We'll also show you
how to run it on various
platforms and model types.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So James, can you tell everyone
what the What-If Tool is
and when they should use it?
JAMES WEXLER: The What-If Tool
is a visual interface designed
to help you understand
your data sets
and the output of your
machine learning models.
You can run with minimal code
from many different platforms,
including Jupyter Notebooks,
Kollab, TensorBoard, and Cloud
AI Platform Notebooks.
Analysis using the
What-If Tool can
be helpful during training data
collection, model creation,
and post-training evaluation.
Sara, you've tried the What-If
Tool on a bunch platforms.
What are the ways
you can use it?
SARA ROBINSON: The What-If Tool
supports TensorFlow models out
of the box and
can support models
built with any other framework
with just a few lines of code.
You can also use
the What-If Tool
with your models deployed
on Cloud AI Platform.
JAMES WEXLER: Let's start
with an example in Kollab.
Here we've trained a TensorFlow
model on this Iowa Housing
data set from Kaggle.
It's a binary
classification model
that predicts whether
a house is worth more
or less than $160,000.
We can instantiate the What-If
Tool with a few lines of code
by passing it a set
of test data points
along with the ground truth
labels for those examples.
The What-If Tool has three
tabs with different features.
And the initial view
we're dropped into
is the data point editor.
Here we can see our model's
prediction for each data point
we've sent to the What-If Tool.
The blue points indicate
houses our model
classified as above $160,000.
In the data point
editor, we can also
inspect individual data
points, change feature values,
create custom visualizations,
and much more.
SARA ROBINSON: The next tab,
Performance and Fairness,
shows a couple of
common evaluation
metrics for our model.
It also lets us slice
data by different features
and apply various strategies
to optimize for fairness.
The final tab,
Features, shows us
how balanced our data set is.
For each feature, we can see
the range of values for the data
we've sent to the What-If Tool.
You can load the Features
tab with only a data set even
before you've trained a model.
JAMES WEXLER: That's awesome.
Do you want to show how you can
use the What-If Tool for models
deployed on Cloud AI Platform?
SARA ROBINSON: Yes.
Here are a few models I've
deployed on AI Platform.
I'll open up an AI Platform
Notebook instance here
to analyze this XGBoost model.
Then I create an instance of the
Wit Config Builder, this time
using the set AI
Platform model method,
passing in my Google Cloud
project ID, model name,
and model version.
The Wit Config Builder
contains more methods
to customize the What-If
Tool for your use case.
JAMES WEXLER: I noticed
two of your models
are trained on
the same data set.
Can you show us how
we can use the What-If
Tool to compare them?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
All I need to do is add a
line to my Wit Config Builder
to tell it which model
I want to compare.
Now you can compare
the performance
of both models using various
capabilities in the What-If
Tool.
I should also
mention that you can
use the What-If Tool for
both classification models
and regression models.
JAMES WEXLER: So to recap,
we've introduced you
to using the What-If Tool on
various platforms and model
types.
Stay tuned for more
videos to learn
what you can do in
the data point editor
and Performance and
Fairness tabs of the tool.
SARA ROBINSON: You can also
check out more What-If Tool
demos in the links below
to see how it works
with image and text models.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]